ladies and gentlemen please welcome Dana
Boyd senior researcher at Microsoft
Research New England good afternoon
thank you so much for coming out today
I put this back here for a second Girl
Clothing microphones always a bad
combination
I want to talk with you today about some
of my work on privacy I've been looking
at how young people you think about and
understand privacy for quite some time
for those who aren't familiar with my
work I'm an ethnographer I spend most of
my time running around the United States
looking at how young people understand
social media as a part of their everyday
life and so my goal today is to talk
about privacy in light of young people
in order to think more generally about
the implications that this has for both
companies and governments now if we
think about young people we've seen a
lot of different kind of social media
disruptions in recent years but what is
it about how do we understand it I think
the most important thing to realize is
that young people use social media as a
part of their everyday life to hang out
with the people that they care about and
they do so in an environment where they
go to the site which is absolutely
common amongst their peers so if they're
in a school where myspace is the
dominant paradigm they're on MySpace
these days it's all about Facebook
increasingly we see new iterations of
new technologies Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest popping out and what we see
from young people's participation is
that it's really driven by where all of
their friends are now a lot of people
look at young people's participation in
these social media and say why are they
spending so much time there and indeed
you can look at the kinds of
conversations that may take place and
they seem to basically boil down to yo
what's up how are you good what you
doing nothing and it's this kind of back
and forth conversation so how do we
actually think about that we can think
of it as a form of social grooming it's
really equivalent to the idea of saying
I like you
we're friends yes we are back and forth
and back and forth and these kind of
dynamics are really the
that makes social media so powerful when
we see young people participating on
these sites they talk about it in terms
of hanging out they talk about it as a
space a space where they can go and be
with their friends joke around laugh you
know and and sort of be a part of
everyday culture with the people that
they know
now it's also a way in which this
material becomes documented it becomes
part of a long ongoing kind of public
and this is actually where the questions
of publicness get complicated so one of
the things that I would argue is that
what young people are doing is that
they're participating in a type of
networked public now publics are the
kinds of spaces that you gather whenever
you're hanging out and you want to
actually be a part of something as a
collective you will gather in physical
public spaces places like parks you know
places you know like the mall for some
of you who are growing up or for young
people their participation in publics is
very much about a networked culture a
networked environment and yet the kinds
of publics that they participate in are
very different than the public's that we
understand traditionally and this is
where a lot of the complications arise
especially when we care about issues
like privacy so I want to go through
four key affordances of these kinds of
networked publics and talk about three
different dynamics in order to ground
this conversation so that we can go into
a broader conversation about privacy
the first key affordance to keep in mind
has to do with persistence what young
people say online sticks around for a
very long time that means that the
embarrassing things that they wrote when
they were teenagers are still on the
internet and I say this as somebody who
grew up online and is amazed that Usenet
is still around has nice little records
of the embarrassing things that I did
it's a really a synchronicity is a
really powerful tool for actually having
conversations but it's also really
challenging when the kinds of content
that you provide in an online
environment stick around another key
affordances that young people have to
navigate has to do with replicability
again the architecture of the Internet
makes it such that it's very easy to
take bits and stand share them and and
in that sharing that process involves a
lot of replication well it's very hard
also determined what was the original
and what was the duplicate and this
process of replicability is something
that young people have to struggle with
when they see information flowing how do
you know what the original was versus
something that was modified this is
actually one of the challenges for young
people when you're not quite sure who
said what
as information spreads and gossip
spreads another key affordance to keep
in mind has to do with search ability my
mother would have loved the ability to
stand in a room and just sort of scream
find like a Harry Potter movie and
figure out where I was off in the ether
she couldn't for which I am deeply
deeply grateful but for a lot of young
people today they're extraordinarily
searchable alright all it takes to
somebody who's curious to know what
they're about a college admissions
officer for example just search for them
yet it's not just that young people are
searchable they're not searchable by
just anyone they're searchable by those
who have hold power over them these are
parents these are teachers these are
people who want to market to them these
are people who want to maybe accept them
for a job and it becomes this challenge
of search ability that be that they have
to navigate as they put content up
online finally the fourth key affordance
to really keep in mind has to do with
scalability now if you put something out
online and any of you who have ever done
any marketing know it may be in theory
able to reach Billy a billion plus
people but in reality not that many
people visit your website right and you
know a couple years back when blogging
was sort of at its peak a site called
Technorati decided to look at how
frequently blogs were read and found
that the average and I do mean average
as a mean the average blog was read by
six people and if you think about that
and you think about sites like Boing
Boing you realize that the vast majority
of blogs are read by no one and so this
becomes a really interesting trick
online is that just because something
can scale to millions and millions of
people doesn't mean it will and young
people quickly learn that that which
scales that which spreads tends to be
that which is most embarrassing
humiliating grotesque
or sexual in fact the things that least
want to spread right and that's where we
have these interesting challenges around
scales how do you deal with an
environment where you're not quite sure
what's going to scale and it's
inevitably the things you least want to
scale now let's think about this in some
of
the dynamics that sort of underpin
what's going on here first there's the
issue of invisible audiences here we are
sitting in Microsoft in Redmond and I
have a sense of you as an audience
you're here on the public day of tech
fest you're coming because your
curiosity you're curious what's
happening at Microsoft Research and I'm
speaking to you in an environment where
I think you at least have some interest
in what I'm saying
but at the other end of that room
there's also a camera pointed at me and
I have no idea who is behind that camera
I have no idea if anything I'm saying
makes sense I don't know if they're
listening to this in 2012 or 2015 I
don't know if they've even heard of
these terms I don't know if might what
I'm saying has been chopped up and
modified right that's an invisible
audience and one of the challenges in an
online environment is that young people
have to navigate invisible audiences
every day as a process of participation
the results of which is that by and
large they try to imagine who their
audience is and it's not just young
people doing this this is adults as well
you have a vision of who you think the
audience should be and in fact that's
actually one of the things about the
friends list the friends list on social
media is in many ways an articulation of
who you want the audience to be who you
imagine it to be and who you think
you're speaking to but how do you
navigate all of these invisible
audiences many adults they like to play
ostrich pretend like those audiences
don't exist young people are hoping that
the invisible audiences might actually
pay attention to them in a positive way
but it's always a challenge another key
dynamic that plays out around this has
to do with collapse contexts again in
this room right now we have an
understanding that this is a lecture and
as a lecture you're supposed to sit
there and pretend like you're paying
attention and nod and smile and look
engaged right that's the rules we've set
up for this room now of course any one
of you could get up and start dancing on
the table right now I would find it
personally very entertaining but it
would completely violate the idea of
what this context is and that doesn't
mean that when you're you know not out
tonight drinking with your friends you
might indeed get up and start dancing
and it'd be fun part of it is how do you
understand what a given context is and a
context is really driven by your
understanding of the space the
environment of what's going on what the
rules and norms are for that space but
also for the people how you relate to
particular people what happens online is
that the context that you're used to
navigating it as discrete contexts
collide in unexpected ways and this is
one of the challenges for you know as we
think about privacy as we think about
these issues of publicity that context
collision is a really hard thing to
navigate third key dynamic that we have
to keep in mind as we think about
privacy has to do with the blurring of
what we'd normally think of as public
and private spaces again we have an
understanding that certain spaces are
more or less public the home is
relatively private
although anybody who has children knows
it's not as private as you want it to be
the you know we have certain ideas of
certain spaces being very public say for
example the park and yet at times we say
very private things in very public
places and vice-versa in an online
environment those boundaries get a lot
more blurred and it's that blurring
where we start to see privacy getting
contested and confused so if this is a
backdrop I want to sort of dive into
some of the ways in which young people
think about and deal with privacy first
I'm gonna start with this great quote
which is a now couple of years old but I
still think it's so poignant that's from
a young woman named Bly and she says my
mom always uses the excuse about the
internet being public when she defends
herself and Bly is referring to her
mother's looking at her online journals
of the time and she's like it's not like
I do anything to be ashamed of but a
girl needs her privacy right and here we
have one of the biggest conflicts about
how young people are struggling to deal
with privacy in an online environment
on one hand she knows that her content
is completely publicly accessible
anybody could look at it but she has
this expectation that her mother is not
supposed to be looking at it that
privacy isn't about whether or not her
content is accessible but what the norms
are that govern that access and that
understanding and here's what we do you
have to think through how young people
deal with privacy it's not about hiding
it's not about excluding oneself from
being part of something instead it's
actually about the ability to have some
sense of control but it's not control
over data which is normally how we talk
about privacy instead it's a two-part
process
one is the ability to have agency the
ability to actually have some sense of
power within a situation and the second
is to understand the social situation
enough to together be able to actually
exert some control over that situation
and that combination the ability to have
agency and the ability to understand and
interpret the rules of the situation are
extraordinarily hard in an online
environment and they're hard for really
complex reasons first off young people
often have their agency usurped by
adults parents who look over their
shoulders for example they also have you
know their understanding of a social
situation undermined by shifting natures
of these technologies where all of a
sudden the privacy settings changed
where all of a sudden new people are on
the environment and they're trying to
deal with it so they're struggling to
exert some form of control that make
sense of them now that doesn't mean that
they're not trying to participate in
these public spaces and it's actually
their participation in these public
settings where you start to see the sort
of fractures that become important so I
didn't give you an example from a woman
named Alicia so Alice Marwick and I
actually went down and interviewed and I
think that she highlights something very
important here because she talks about
some of those shifts and her struggles
with it she says I just think that
technology is redefining what's
acceptable for people to put out about
themselves I've grown up with technology
so I don't know how it was before this
boom of social networking but it seems
like instead of spending all of our time
talking to other individual people and
sharing things that would seem private
we spent our time putting it up in one
module of communication where people can
go and access it if they want to right
now what she's highlighting is a shift
that has happened a shift because of the
technical affordances and she doesn't
even realize the importance of that
shift but I want to sort of play it out
for you if we were having a conversation
say in the hallway our interaction would
be in many ways private by default
public with effort it would be private
by default just because the conversation
could only be overheard so far it would
be public by effort because if you
wanted to share what we talked about you
would have to go out of your way to
publicize it it would take these steps
to publicize it and so we make it
then about what to publicize yet in an
online environment these things swap
this goes to the absolute opposite
direction that participation in social
media is in many ways public by default
private through effort our interactions
online it's easier to put them up and
make them broadly accessible and then
choose what to exclude and indeed that's
what we see young people doing on a
regular basis that they actually choose
what to exclude from public discourse as
opposed to what to include and that
shift is really really confusing to
people because if you're not prepared
for it you sit there and say why are you
sharing your breakfast I don't want to
know about your breakfast when the
inverse attitude is there's nothing
wrong with sharing my breakfast I might
as well share it and if you don't like
it you'll move on right and that's a
really radical shift in terms of
navigating these issues part of it has
to do with the fact that young people
are not trying to be public they're not
trying to be seen by everybody across
all space and all time but rather
they're trying to find a public that
they can participate in and this is
really important in light especially of
an American context where young people
have few opportunities to engage with
their peers in an unstructured setting a
place where they can just hang out and
those spaces those publics become
extraordinarily important to them so
they look to social media as an attempt
to find a public that they can
participate in but it doesn't mean that
they're trying to be public and that's
an important distinction now as I'm
participating in those publics though
they don't understand why other people
don't understand the rules of the those
publics why adults don't see that this
is not a space for them and inevitably
there are constant complaints about
teachers or parents what are they doing
looking at this material they don't
belong there and this is where we start
to see young people trying to develop
strategies and so I want to highlight
are the kinds of stuff you know a few
examples of strategies that young people
take to achieve privacy many of these
have parallels in an offline setting but
I'm gonna talk about them in an online
setting because I think that they're
important I'm gonna begin with a young
person by the name of Hunter and Hunter
is a young man living in DC and he's
dealing with very
context collapses in his world he is
going to a private not a private public
charter school that's really for really
intelligent highly academic young people
um he's really excited about his school
he likes being a part of this a key
environment but he also comes from a
working-class environment that is very
different he likes to talk about it and
particularly talk about his sister as
quote-unquote ghetto um and so one of
the things she's dealing with on
Facebook is that he has to deal with
these conflicting worlds about how he
has sai-multaneously interactions with
his his friends and his peers and with
his sister and so what he says here is
when I'm talking to my friends on
Facebook or I put up a status something
I hate is when people who I'm not
addressing my statuses comment on them
in my old school people used to always
call me nerdy and then I was the least
black black person they've ever met some
would say that on Facebook and I you
know I'd say should I take offense to
the fact that someone put the ringtone
white and nerdy is for me and it was a
joke
I guess we were all talking about it and
my sister comes out of nowhere and she's
like oh baby bro and I'm like no don't
say that I wasn't talking to you okay so
asking Hunter about this is like how are
you supposed to navigate this and he's
like well it's just I think there are
certain ways you talk you know she was
pointing out he would talk to his sister
differently than he would talk to his
friends and he really thought his sister
should know this and he constantly
struggled because no amount of asserting
of the social norms meant that his
sister got it so instead he started
actually developing technical means to
keep people out
Hunter and his friends at school were
really interested in old classic video
games and other other material which by
the way I get it pains me where his
notion of classic video games was the
legends of Zelda which makes me feel
sufficiently old but he was talking
about how he loved to geek out on
legends of Zelda and about Pokemon but
if he would write about these things on
Facebook his cousins and his sister
would make fun of him because what was
cool within that group was much more in
the world of shooter video games and so
he got to a point where he decided that
any time he would talk about Pokemon or
legends of Zelda he would go out of his
way to block people and he would make a
special list just to talk about these
things not because he was trying to hide
these is
Zelda but he didn't want to deal with
the Contacts collisions he didn't want
to deal with the awkward dynamics
between different people this is one of
the strategies for achieving privacy
it's a very technical strategy but it's
also one of the things that's really
hard to do and so young people are
dealing with that and the next two
strategies I'm going to give you are
very technical strategies and they're
very unique to the two young women that
I'm going to talk about but they're
important to highlight the kinds of
extremes that young people will go to
the first has to do with a young woman
by the name of Shamika that we met in DC
and Shamika was constantly dealing with
drama in her school and she was
frustrated because people would go back
way into facebook and take things from
you know long time ago as in like a
month or two months ago and they would
bring it back to the forefront and they
would turn it into a big deal so she got
to a point where when she would log into
Facebook she would read a comment that
was left to her and then she would
delete it and she would go and she would
leave comments on other people's sites
other people's pages she would mark
things up and then the next day she
would go and she would delete the
messages she left and she talked about
it in terms of basically keeping
Facebook perfectly clean perfectly empty
there was no long-term or persistent
record of Facebook right and it didn't
mean that she didn't think that it could
be recorded in fact you know one of the
things we asked her is that you know
well Facebook has a copy of this where
your friends can copy and she's like
yeah but if you go to that much effort
you're really creepy right it was a
recognition that this was a way of
signaling to her peers that pulling this
stuff from the past was not appropriate
makalah which was a result so from DC it
was dealing with a different set of
dynamics she was dealing with the fact
that she's under state supervision she's
in foster care she's dealing with
different dynamics in terms of adults
looking in on her life on a regular
basis and she knew that they were
looking for online records of what she
was doing
so when Facebook put together a feature
to every story when Facebook decided
that it didn't want people to delete
their accounts when it gave them was an
option where if you go to try to delete
your account it would say really you
don't want to do that just to activate
it and if you feel like coming back
everything will be there for you well
Michaela took that to an extreme so what
would happen is is that
every day at the end of her use of
Facebook she would deactivate her
account that would render her entirely
invisible in the system it would mean
nobody could message her it mean that
nobody could see her profile and then
the next day when she would log back in
she would reactivate her account and her
account was basically invisible except
at all points except during the moments
in which she was logged in right she
made it a real-time activity pretty
powerful way of going about this and
when I was asking her about you know why
how does this play out she's like well
you know no but no adult looks at this
at night right which is again this sort
of way of trying to understand the
circumstances and exactly some sort of
control over it now these are extreme
approaches but I want to talk about a
sort of more common approach carmen was
a young woman that we met in
Massachusetts and Carmen really loved
her mother they were super super close
she was super excited to have her mother
on Facebook with her there was all sorts
of good dialogues but she couldn't stand
when her mother would sort of over react
to things and her mother had this
tendency to want to comment on
everything and as carmen points out is
that is a little overwhelming because
everybody disappears after the mom post
right so when mom comments no one
responds well the other thing about
Carmen's mom is that Carmen's mom tends
to overreact to what Carmen says
especially emotional things and so
Carmen's always trying to find a way to
convey emotions to her friends without
them overreacting or without her mom
overreacting one day Carmen and her
boyfriend break up and she's having a
pretty crappy day and she wants to
explain this to her friends
she or she wants to sort of gather some
sort of support and so she thinks about
you know expressing herself and as a
teenager expressing herself and her
emotions means putting up song lyrics
but she knew if he put up any sort of
sappy song lyric that her mother would
go you know crazy and would think she
was suicidal so she decided to do
something which she knew would not be
visible to her parent her mother but
would be to her friends she decided to
put up song lyrics from always look on
the bright side of life now for those
who don't get the Monty Python reference
this is a very chipper and happy song
always look on the bright side of life
some during a part of the movie where
the key character is about to be
executed it is not a happy
Sene and she knew that her friends had
just recently seen this movie she knew
that it was outside of the cultural
purview of her mother and so she puts up
these song lyrics her mother immediately
comments oh it looks like you're having
a great day and her friends immediately
call her right and this is a really
powerful tactic for achieving privacy in
a public environment it's something that
in many ways we've understood especially
in the computer science world as
steganography
it's a cryptographic notion of hiding in
plain sight and what Carmen is doing is
a form of social steganography she is
making it possible to convey a really
detailed message while hiding in plain
sight now I've been talking to young
people for the better part of a decade
and one of the things that I find really
startling over the decade that I've been
looking at social media is how I
increasingly cannot tell what they're
talking about on social media and it's
not because I don't understand the
cultural references I can I i watch way
too much TV I know way too much about
teen music but it's the fact that I am
actually not located within their peer
group I don't know they're in jokes and
most of what they're starting to do in
social media is put up a whole set of
encoded information there they're
conveying a lot of detailed private
information because but I can't make
sense of it and what we see is that
young people have found that the most
reasonable tactic for achieving privacy
in a networked public environment is to
make the content itself perfectly
accessible but make certain that the
meaning is not at all accessible and
that is extremely powerful it's not just
young people that are doing this we're
starting to see this as adults and a
whole group of people it's also not
entirely new and one of the things that
I find interesting talking to activists
in particular is how this was a tactic
of oppressed populations forever
right and so again what do we think
about teenagers as an oppressed
population something to sort of leave
and ponder with so I want to sort of
roll this forward and what does this
mean as we start to go forward many of
you in the room are interested in all
sorts of different notions of privacy
issues of data privacy issues of you
know how to deal with the complex big
data problems that we're starting to see
and most of what I've just been talking
about is what I would call social
privacy I think it's important to
recognize that there are all of these
conflicting issues with privacy that are
coming up and emerging young people in
many ways are paying no attention to
what companies or what governments are
doing they don't know how to make sense
of it it's not within a cultural frame
of course there's a lot of great you
know scholarly data that shows that
adults also have no clue what's
happening with companies or governments
either so it's not that young people are
especially clueless it's pretty much
that everyone has no clue what's going
on but what is clear even from the
social privacy work that I sort of
highlight is the importance of agency
and all of this that what young people
are trying to do in an environment of
data is actually have some sort of
agency and what they don't want is that
agency undermined they're attentive to
having their agency undermined by
parents and teachers law enforcement
college admissions officers they don't
even know how to grapple with larger
entities and I would say that's true for
adults as well but I think it's
important that you know one of the key
takeaways here is that it's important to
make certain that we're empowering users
in a way where they can actually have
some sorts of agency and that we don't
undermine that as we think about the
kinds of privacy issues that we have
going forward another key issue has to
do with the fact that young people just
because young people are willing to be
public doesn't mean that they're making
everything transparent it doesn't mean
that you actually understand what's
going on and I have a field day watching
you know data mining processes where
people think they know what's going on
and I'll say one of my most awkward
encounters ever as I was on a panel this
is now quite a few years ago and a
representative from coca-cola was on the
panel with me and was really proudly
announcing how everybody had made
friends with coke on various social
media sites and I sat there really
awkwardly and I was like that's not the
coke that they're referring to right and
that was one of those moments where
you're just like you don't really want
to talk about these things that's not
something you want to lovely proclaim so
part of it is is as we see this data we
get so excited about what's going on
with data do we understand it and more
often than not I think that we don't and
I think that's going to be a complex
issue but there's also another component
to this which is that young people want
to have a
of trust with the people that they're
revealing data to and how are we dealing
with all of the power dynamics including
the role of government and companies in
this just because young people are
putting up data does not mean that they
want it to be read by everybody and even
if they're not imagining the roles of
companies and governments
they're definitely measuring the roles
of those who have power over them and
they're not happy with it so how do we
deal with that dynamic as we go forward
another key issue I think to hold in the
back of our heads has to do with network
privacy just because you know we talk
about individual privacy harms doesn't
mean that that's what's playing out
right now and more and more of the data
that we deal with are really about
networks privacy and what I mean by that
is that take take something as mundane
as an email who controls the email the
sender the recipient who should have the
ownership rights over what privacy
regulates that email now ratchet it up
and deal with it in more complex spaces
take something like DNA right I may
choose as an individual not to reveal my
DNA but if my mother and daughter do my
DNA is for all intents and purposes very
visible how do we deal with privacy when
we can't think about it in terms of
individual models and for the lawyers in
the room this is one of the biggest
challenges is how to actually build out
a networks privacy model when we have a
legal regime that thinks about
individual harm and this is one of
things I don't think we're there yet and
I think is going to be a complicated
battle over the next couple of years now
companies and governments are very much
forced to grapple with how to deal with
privacy and we're almost always focused
on giving users control but we actually
have to think about what we mean by that
and what we mean by informed consent
when users are pressured to participate
either by the companies or by their
friends that's not really consent and
when people don't understand what's
going on consent isn't consent more
often than not in the privacy realm
right now no one understands what's
happening even the people that are
building the systems so how are we going
to get some sort of meaningful consents
in an environment where we want to give
people control but they don't even know
what to do with that and I would say
this as a user who is extremely you know
confident about my own ways of
navigating
spaces and I don't know how to deal with
this so how do we expect this of people
who are not as technologically literate
most of our models right now are also
really focused on the ideas of
collection of data and that once we've
collected we can do whatever we want
with the data and I would argue that
this is extraordinarily problematic we
really need to be clear about our usage
of data and start to have these
conversations think for example the most
recent New York Times article about the
challenges that target faced if those
who haven't read it I really recommend
looking up this article because part of
it is is that they were collecting data
in a perfectly reasonable way but the
ways in which they used it made their
their customers extremely uncomfortable
so how do we work through these
different usage paradigms how do we
think about it and not just how do we
think about it in a regulatory regime
although I fear if we don't figure out
how to deal with it we will be dealing
with it in a regulatory regime and I'm
not saying that that's not going to make
it any easier I think we need to have
critical conversations about what this
data looks like keep in mind that people
want to participate in public life
whether that public life is networked or
whether it is a face-to-face encounter
they want to be a part of what's going
on and public life today involves a
tremendous amount of data it's gonna be
filled with all sorts of privacy
challenges and privacy is not going to
just disappear people aren't gonna get
over it privacy is not dead people are
gonna keep wanting to have ways of
having agency and control in their life
and we need to figure out how to help
them through that figuring out how to
navigate data in an in a complex system
figuring out how to deal with data in a
networked system is so important and
this is gonna be a challenge for each
and every one of you and I really hope
you and you come with us and help
struggle with these issues and so
hopefully together we can find solutions
thank you